[Music]
in our morning rounds treating seasonal
allergies through virtual doctor visits
allergies are the sixth leading cause of
chronic illness in the u.s. did you know
that they affect 16 million American
adults and more than 5 million children
dr. Tara nurullah shows us how doctors
are delivering help so patients don't
even have to leave home I know for most
people they don't like to go the doctor
so I'm thinking this is a good thing
[Laughter]
with spring allergies in full bloom the
wait to see a specialist in person can
be several weeks but scheduling a
same-day visit through telemedicine is
virtually a click away an explosion of
tree pollen this spring is setting off
Dylan Kirsch's allergies instead of
taking him for an office visit Dylan's
mother Lisa sits with him at the kitchen
table for a virtual visit with
pediatrician Sylvia wrong a lot of
congestion you get something called
allergic shiners which means that you
get these dark circles under your eyes
open your eyes look up you can have the
parent pull down the eyelid can you see
them there's a particular type of
symptom in the throat called cobblestone
and that's the post nasal drip that
comes from allergies and then makes him
a little bit more towards the camera
okay so it doesn't look terrible to me
so he's been taking allergy medicine for
two days today was your follow up how
did the follow physical the follow-up is
oh it's great it was wonderful because I
didn't have to pull him out of school
and make an appointment in the middle of
the day take a day off from work to do
this kids actually love video visits
because they know the doctor can't give
them any shots that over the last five
years allergist Tonya Eliot has made
about 7,000 remote house calls finding
clues she wouldn't see in her office
it's about having carpets having drapes
curtains decorative pillows upholstered
furniture so those are the things that
we discuss when we talk about the first
line of treatment which is allergen
avoidance
a recent study led by
dr. Elliott identified potential
benefits including faster diagnosis and
medication prescribing lower
out-of-pocket costs and access for
people in remote areas do you feel like
it got any better at all researchers
also found face to face screen time
might improve the doctor-patient
relationship
it's all about building rapport and
active listening and facial expressions
that then establish that connection with
the patient before adding another
medication then is the air filter and
then we can check we can check back in
on that great thank you dr. ROM the
telehealth industry is expected to grow
to 36 billion dollars by 2020 right now
34 states and Washington DC require
insurance companies to cover virtual
visits the same as they do for office
visits but of course services like shots
still have to take place in person just
for shots again yeah boob regardless of
where they take but I know that they're
very important so I get it Kara thank
you thank you